I am Buzz Aldrin and I receive lunar
module pilot on Apollo 11 five four
three two one zero all engine running
liftoff we have a liftoff 32 minutes
past the hour liftoff on Apollo 11
power cleared I believe that this nation
should commit itself to achieving the
goal before this decade is out of
landing a man on the moon and returning
him safely to the earth
no single space project in this period
will be more impressive to mankind or
more important for the long-range
exploration of space and none will be so
difficult or expensive to accomplish
[Music]
everything looked normal when we
separated little communications problems
with earth but then when we got to the
point of lighting the engine for power
decent Neel said I think we might be a
little long
well how could he tell that he had some
lines marked on the map and looking at
the watch clock we had we were we get to
a point looking down we were gonna want
a yacht around and that the landing
radar begin to correct the knowledge
that the computer had of exactly what
the orbit is angle s van pH - Niner
y'all +18 then shortly after that
happened we began to get some program
alarms which interrupted the displays
now the displays to the crew from the
computer were pretty basic there were
three registers of a lot of numbers and
you
to know what each one of those meant but
now they were blanked because we had
this program alarm and so we asked
houston what the problem was if we're
still go on that after a few minutes
they came back and said we're going that
alarm we continued down but it tended to
distract a little bit a little bit but
we are still on a good landing
trajectory as the lander gets down to
about 500 feet the commander
nobody has ever really maneuvered and
checked the response of the landing
craft and so all the commanders agreed
that at 500 feet they would begin to
manually control toward what looked like
reasonable landings black and everything
still appeared to be okay and I could
see and and Neal also wanted to avoid a
crater that was in front of us
[Music]
[Applause]
forward forward
but when we were at about a hundred feet
now Neil is looking out the window and
manually controlling him and I'm giving
him the numbers of the altitude the
altitude rate or descent rate and the
speed over the ground and I keep
updating with that information at about
a hundred feet there's a light that
comes on as a fuel quantity light and
about that time the capsule communicator
Charlie Duke says okay under feet 67 we
better ease downs what I'm saying but I
don't want to disturb Neil by saying
hurry up hurry up human I thought a
little further 30 seconds
but we're ten feet I figured we got it
made when the landing gear is just about
to touch there are probes that come down
about five six feet and as soon as they
hit the ground they will Bend dessert
it's supposed to bend and that sets a
micro switch and that lights light in
the cabin and that's when I said I'm
back right of course Neil is looking out
we've been doing controlling it but
that's the first indication of actually
touching down and then we actually
touched down with the fourth here and I
call out a few things we need to do like
shut off the engine tranquility we copy
on the ground you got a bunch of guys
about to turn blue we're breathing again
thanks a lot so we touched out and I
think the estimate not because somebody
put a dipstick in the fuel to see how
much was left but it was calculations
and information on board we probably had
about 15 seconds of fuel left
there's really no place on earth that we
could simulate a gravity of one-sixth of
what we have here so there really wasn't
a great simulation because of that we
were scheduled at the bottom of the
ladder to just hold on and sort of see
what it was like
under the gravity Neil went down first
and he did things I could see him
through the window
he had no trouble at all just moving
around
Samantha so I knew that there wasn't
gonna be any trouble for me to move
around
so walking was relatively easy we could
I demonstrated several means near the
end of our stay on the surface in front
of the TV camera and that was planned up
here if we had the time and it looked to
people back on earth as if I was just
having fun but I was really doing
something for people to observe their
ease of mobility so we went through the
countdown and when the call came from
Earth you're cleared for takeoff I can
end ahead when I was going to say now
when the lunar module takes off it's
about 1g but that's six times the
gravity so we leave breathe pretty
rapidly
the ascend engine is fixed so it's a
rather sloppy feeling but it's what's
expected there's nothing wrong and when
the engine cutoff we already a good on
it some way when those two Americans
stepped on the moon the people of this
world were rocked closer together that
it is that spirit the spirit of Apollo
that America can now help to bring to
our relations with other nations the
spirit of Apollo transcends geographical
barriers and political differences it
can bring the people of the world
together in peace
[Music]
[Music]
you